i was impressed in your new book that
you were talking about how you decided
to protest
to go to washington dc and even get
arrested and you know
you don't make any secret about your age
you're 82 at this point and you're
saying
i'm going to go to washington and get
arrested this is sticking with me that
the police officer
how to push you into a van so [ __ ]
degrading
you know jane fonda being pushed into a
van and everything
i know most people who are in their 80s
are not
even going to walk outside and get
themselves arrested
oh but there were so many old women
there
there were more old women that were of
anybody else
old women are leading this charge
believe me i mean what the hell do we
have to lose and women tend to get much
much braver as they get older so we're
we're leading this thing and that's true
and that's true globally
but you know i figured because i'm old
people are going to say she's she's 82
if she can do it i can do it
and so people kept coming from all over
the country i mean i know a ton of
people say what do i care i'm going to
be dead so what's the difference but i
go don't you have kids don't you have
you know grandchildren don't you i mean
you don't care about them i
i don't know how you do that i think
it's important especially if you're old
to think about your
your you're dying you know and kind of
like how do you want to go
out and we never know how we're going to
die we can't control it but
sort of i like to imagine that i'm i'm
in my deathbed and i'm surrounded by
people
i love i want to be able to not have a
lot of regrets i want to feel
okay about myself like i my life had
some meaning
if i wasn't doing what i'm doing now
knowing what i know
about the dangers that we're facing i
would
arrive at the end of my life hating
myself
not being able to look my loved ones in
the eye
you know i i just i i don't want to you
have to plan
for how you want to be and how you want
to feel when you get to the end
you can't wait till you get to that's
what my dad did he didn't plan so he got
to the end and he had a lot of regrets
and that i don't want to do that so if
you know something is wrong
and you don't do everything that you can
to make it right
you're gonna you're gonna get to the end
of your life with
so many bad feelings and regrets
i wouldn't be able to sleep right now i
was really i was really depressed before
i went to dc
because i knew i wasn't doing enough i'm
famous so i have a platform and i didn't
know how to use it
you